one of the things that characterizes our
society is the abundance of credit the
reliance on credit and for a few months
now I've been telling you that I was
going to make a video on credit and I
haven't done it yet because when I try
to wrap my wrap my head around it you
know I always hit these walls where I'm
not incapable of encompassing the entire
concept of credit and its effect on us
so I decided that I will try to maybe
deal with certain aspects of credit and
talk about it in several videos maybe as
I flesh this out for myself as well and
so the first video that I'm doing now
this idea of credit is going to be
related to the manner in which credit
seems to be accelerating time and so
hopefully we'll be able to find some
insight there
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so before I start I want to remind
everybody that as you know I am still in
this chaotic flood period of my life I
am have been decided to emphasize the
videos and the patreon because it has
become let's say the main way in which
I'm able to support my family and so
every month now for until further notice
I'm going to put out a patron only video
last month it was about Jack in the
Beanstalk and this month it is about the
princess and the pea and strangely
enough you will notice that there's a
relationship between those two stories
so if you're interested in seeing those
videos please sign up on my patreon on
my website or on subscribe' Sarsour he
would go with credit now the the
importance of credit in terms of time
and noticing the effect of credit on
time can be understood when we look at
the notion of sacrifice and the
relationship between credit and
sacrifice one of the the way is that
Jordan Peterson has framed the notion of
sacrifice I feel it has been very useful
in helping us understand sacrifice in a
broader sense and also the way that we
used the notion of sacrifice today is
the idea that sacrificing something not
always but often in ancient sacrifice
you sacrifice something
now you sacrifice some precious thing
the best calf the best sheep or whatever
you know you sacrifice a percentage of
your of your crop of whatever it is that
you have in the notion that what it's
going to do is going to provide it's
going to provide something for the
future that is you're making a deal with
God in in in the Jewish world in other
words you make me deal with the gods
that you're giving them something and
then they will provide for you in the
future
some form of stability some form of
blessing something which will come later
and the manner in which Jordan has
framed it in terms of the modern world
today is that we still do that today we
have this idea that we can sacrifice
something you know that I can sacrifice
part of my
then I can sacrifice some benefit that I
have right now in in a deal with the
future that is looking towards the
future I am willing to put something
aside today sacrifice something today so
that I will get something in the future
and you can see that even when your own
children that is you when you have
children you sacrifice yourself for your
children because you believe in their
potential in what they will bring to the
world to you too to their own lives and
to yourself in the future and so what's
interesting about credit is
understanding it that way when we borrow
money we are doing something which could
be considered like the opposite of
sacrifice so if sacrifice is taking
something I have today sacrificing it
for in order to receive more for the
future you could call it a kind of
investment you could say in the future
credit is the opposite credit is
borrowing from the future right till you
take something from the future and you
bring it to you today
now in the ancient world the the was an
interesting symbolic relationship that
was happening because what you would do
is in Europe and within Judaism and
let's say within Christianity it was
immoral to borrow with interest or to
lend with interest within your community
and you had in order for you to have
access to something like credit you had
to borrow from the outside and that of
course is the the opportunities that
were there for the Jews in Middle Ages
and during the early modern period and
also the downfall that the difficulty
that they faced was that that the
Christians would be borrowing from the
foreigner now you can see how there's a
relationship between that between the
notion of borrowing from the future
if you imagine a space a space that has
its own identity its own Center its own
cohesion and the outside of that space
is not is its potentiality you could
call it and it is it's chaos is
potentiality but it's also the foreigner
and so you can imagine that that's where
you get the your future potential is
from the outside either you can imagine
it as a Empire that's getting bigger or
you can imagine it as a trade with the
outside in order to increase your
possibilities now so borrowing from the
the foreigner and was also symbolically
related to the notion of borrowing from
the future and so you you borrow from
the future and you bring it into the
present so that you can have something
now that is actually should have you
should have gotten from the future that
you haven't saved up for and you haven't
kept money for yourself right now and so
then what it does is it creates a sense
that you now need to accelerate your
work here today in order to pay off the
loans and also in order to pay off the
interest on the loan so the interest on
the loan is a fascinating thing because
it's a kind of living thing it's a kind
of monster which exists on the edge and
if you if you make a deal with it it
will grow it's like you you you you you
take from the future and the side effect
of that is this monster of interest
which gets bigger if you don't attend to
it now one of the things that happened
at the end of the Middle Ages which is
very fascinating is that the rule for
usury which is this notion that you are
not allowed to lend with interest at
least not in most circumstances there
there are always exceptions to these
types of rules but you are not allowed
to lend in a manner which was to bring
you back interest that law started to go
away and there's a famous instances of
martin luther approving the possibility
of lending with interest and certain of
the reformers accepting
the credit and interest within the
community now as this happened what
there's something about you know when
you would deal with the foreigner and
you borrow from the foreigner you're
always aware of the difficulty that
you're facing because if you borrow from
someone who's not part of your group you
are making yourself indebted to them you
are giving them power you're giving
power to the future but you're also
giving power to your potential to the
potentiality that's outside you and
giving power to the to some foreign
force that's on the on the margin of
your world and so you have to always be
careful not to give too much power to
the outside because if you give too much
power to the outside at some point the
the tables will flip and you will become
subject to the outside you know you can
understand that in terms of like I
always give you the image of in terms of
your own passions you know you have
these marginal things on your outside
these these things that are pulling you
if you give too much power to that thing
that's pulling you away from your Center
at some point it's things are going to
flip and you will become like a slave to
that thing which is which is outside you
and so the the uneasy relationship
between the the Christians and the
outsiders in the Middle Ages you know
was a difficult one because it was
always this uneasy thing on the one hand
we want to be able to borrow from the
outside in order to increase our
capacity to do things today but we
always have to be careful because if we
do it too much we become indebted to the
to the outside and the outside starts to
exercise power on us now once the once
that process was brought inside the the
community that is that people could lend
to themselves with interest the the
problem seems to seem to have gone away
because all then that was left was this
notion of the future which is that as I
borrow from someone with interest then I
am bringing something from the future
into myself and like I said what that
does is it accelerates time now you can
see it if I just say something like
you're literally literally should never
use that word you're taking the future
and you're bringing it towards yourself
so you're taking something that you
don't have that you think that you'll
have enough for in the future by paying
off the loan and you bring it towards
yourself in order to have it now and so
you're actually accelerating time by
doing that but with that what that makes
it happen that you now have to be more
productive now so you have to grow
faster and you have to put more effort
into into growth now in order to pay off
the indebtedness that you had towards
the future so what's fascinating to see
is how that process which started at the
end of the Middle Ages in the
Reformation and in the early modern
period has grown and accelerated and has
taken up more in more space to a point
where our entire economy is based on
credit our entire economy is based on
interest the the fact that the
government owes a certain amount with
interest to those who have bought barns
or or have invested in the country and
so that is actually what makes our money
valuable is the fact that we have to pay
back with interest those that have
borrowed those that have that have lent
money to the government and so you have
this weird internal acceleration which
is necessarily going to happen and what
it does obviously it causes necessary
inflation as well so the prices keep
going up and we keep having to speed up
the the the wheel in order to constantly
deal with that problem but the problem
is growing and growing and growing and
it's interesting to watch the monster
grow now one of the problems we have is
that for example we are we we over
budget you know we see that in Canada in
all these countries people will over
budget in the idea that in the future we
will be more productive than we are now
and so we borrow from the future we saw
the boomers did that to us especially
you know they borrowed from the
future in order to have all these
pension plans and have all this stuff
and we obviously don't have that but the
process is still ongoing because we
we're borrowing from the future we we in
the idea that we will be so much more
productive later but then that doesn't
totally totally happen at least not fast
enough so we have to borrow more and
more and more and it's it's extremely
fascinating because at some point this
interest keeps growing so one of the
things we're seeing happen at say in our
countries for example is we are one of
the things that we have to budget for
let's say in there in Canada in the US
is the same we have to budget in the
year for the government spending on a
certain amount which we need to pay the
interest on what we owe to ourselves to
other countries to whatever so we have
to at least pay the interest on what
we're borrowing and so it's it's it's
really interesting to watch all the
interest on these on this loan keeps
growing and growing and growing and so
we have to budget more and we have to
budget more and more of our budget in
order to finance that loan one of the
things they do is they end up now
budgeting more and more and more to
account for the interest that is being
borrowed and at some point that's going
to catch up that is at some point the
interest is going to get so big and is
going to Tech is going to eat like a
monster it's got actually going to eat
our budget to a point where it's going
to become untenable what happens when
half of the budget of a country is is
used to pay back the interest on the on
the money that it owes what happens when
that gets even bigger and bigger and
bigger at some point there is a collapse
and sadly I have to say that this is
this has been a kind of weird way in
which this is kind of horrible to say
but this has been a weird way in which
the world has been able to avoid war
which it has been to imagine growth by
borrowing from the future but at some
point that that balance is going to
collapse
and the only thing left at after that is
going to be war we're going to see the
inevitability of some countries who will
want to stabilize their economy have to
increase their power just like the
ancient empires did not by borrowing
from the future but by taking from that
which surrounds it and it seems like at
some point that will become an
inevitable reality sadly it's sad that I
have to say that but we have to brace
ourselves for that possibility because
this this this borrowing from the future
at some point you know this cycle of
time the serpent will come and eat its
own tail and then at that point you know
everything breaks apart but then
everything starts again not always in a
positive manner so I hope that this
little thought these little thoughts on
credit and on interest were of interest
to you I will keep thinking about it
there are a lot of things I still need
to think about for example you know the
representation of the talents in the
Bible of God giving talents that need to
be returned with more with interest the
idea of in the Lord's Prayer how we say
when we say forgive us our our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us can also be read as
forget our us our debts as we forgive
our debtors and so that is something
that we need to understand what is the
relationship between credit and loan and
interest and the spiritual life but
that's something that I still need to
think about especially because it has
been so thought about only in moral
terms or in legal terms
Allah Allah Luther and allied Nietzsche
a for example and I think there's
another way to conceive of it which
would be useful to address and so once
again guys thank you for your support I
hope you enjoyed this video and I will
see all of you soon if you enjoy the
symbolic world content there's a lot of
things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website